jerry albums we are sitting in a hotel
right on the irish border which will in
due course be the place on tarmac where
the european union ends and the united
kingdom begins how do you police that
without some kind of border control
well you can't and we've been saying
from day one of the referendum result
that the only outcome if the frontier
between the european union and the non
european union is on the aid and the
violent then it's going to be a hard
economic frontier and you know we are
sitting on the border as you say and if
you go to either side here you just see
how it's Nick's you know even as you
look here one thing will be on the
border the other fear will be on the
other side of the border and that's the
nature of it so we have argued in chin
vein and the irish parliament has voted
and supported this and all of the
parties elected the majority of them
there ml as to the assembly in the north
support the proposition of a special
designated status for the north that's
the only way to stop a hard frontier
being erected here but why would a
British Prime Minister accept special
designated status for Northern Ireland
within the European Union given that
that really would be a united Ireland by
the back door
well it wouldn't be because it wouldn't
infringe on the constitutional issue
that can only be sorted out of a
majority of people in the north and in
the south vote for nanami united ireland
and want to see nothing
Allisyn terms I just think it's sensible
it isn't just an emotional thing I just
think that in a small land mass like
this with such a small population unity
means a good economy unity means good
health services it means decent
environment good energy use and all the
rest of it but we have to date both what
is essentially an English problem the
English government because they're
ignoring what the people of Scotland
want they're ignoring what the people of
the north of Ireland one
there's not to them because the European
Council or the Commission or the
Parliament in other words the other
European to 2627 States they will decide
what's going to help you talk a little
bit about Scotland there Scotland's
First Minister has sent a letter to
dining Strait demanding a referendum on
Scottish independence if you believe
people here would vote for Irish unity
at this point why have you not sent a
similar letter demanding a referendum
well we're exploring the situation and
Scotland slightly more advanced and is
and the two aren't to see him anyway so
we're exploring the context in which we
may do that with with the two
governments I'm content that we should
have at a bit that we should look at the
merits as I would see it or the demurrer
says maybe a unionist might see it and
I'm also very very conscious that
Republicans should not be seen in any
way exploiting the consequences of our
acts because the type of item we want
has to be one in which unionism which
you knows decent unions are content that
needs to be agreed any of them they are
please it needs the respect everything
that they want in terms of the way
forward
it can't be like you know put put in the
shoe on the other foot what we don't
want I don't want you know as someone
who was born into a state that didn't
want me I don't want and you are ending
anything other than a harmonious
fraternity of all the people who live on
this island
it's not too harmonious at Stormont
right now and the absence of a devolved
government is just a complication in
terms of what's going on with brexit hi
has Sinn féin come from a position of
being willing to share par with
unionists to being reluctant to do that
over what many people would say is
relatively minor issues like an Irish
language act well you're right and so
far as the issues we have to deal with
are not as difficult as issues which
we've dealt with in the past and
resolved in the past and I picked up to
our union's partners and course of the
the recent talks and it isn't that we're
reluctant to sharp our and I believe
fully and we're wedded to the Good
Friday Agreement done to the political
institutions but as Mark McGinnis said
there can be no return to the status quo
so what went wrong was that terms of
previous agreements on the cards were
not implemented were not delivered and
when yet somebody is big under strong
and as formidable as Martin he could
carry that to a certain degree for their
estimates Martin's gone so any Aiden if
we were able to cobble together
something tomorrow it wouldn't last
so I wanted to be sustainable one of the
other issues on the negotiating table of
course his legacy and fortune fair and
that's about getting British soldiers in
the dark but many people would say what
about the victims of IRA violence what
about their right to justice well I
didn't know but getting British soldiers
in the dark it's about the victims of
British soldiers been treated exactly
the same as the victims of the IRA or
any other combatant force arborisation
has been for an international
independent Truth Commission that
everybody can make use of but we
compromised on this issue and yes I
believe that victims of the IRA or at
least their relatives have the right to
truth and I believe that those who are
victims of British Army violence or
state violence also have the right to
truth and the British government is
holding that back the Lord Chief Justice
has said in terms of legacy and quest
for example that the funding should be
made available there's funding set aside
under that agreement British government
is refusing to
[Music]
issue that funding and some of these
families have fought Brennan quest and I
know in one case for 43 years so that's
not per journey you talk about those
mechanisms perhaps for treatment
reconciliation six months ago Martin
Beginner's told me if those mechanisms
existed he was quite prepared to talk
about his past if they existed with
Gerry Adams find it easier to talk about
his past and his long alleged
involvement in the IRA yes I I have said
and Martin and I said this together and
what said it quite a few times that we
would both do our best and we would also
encourage all the Republicans to come
forward if to resist our structural
arrangements and that's my that's my
commitment Martin's not here but that's
still my commitment in his eulogy
President Clinton said Martin McGinnis
had been married to Gerry Adams for
nearly as long as he'd been married to
his wife Bertha you must miss him
terribly
yes I do I miss him in terms of the
daily grind of the work that we're doing
this is the very first and this is from
1972 the first talks process that he and
I haven't been together but I miss him
also at a personal level deeply so on I
I sort of reconcile myself to that
because I know you have to go through a
grieving process so many people knew
Martin McGuinness II was it was a
fixture for decades
he's more awful than me he's more like
going in me he's not as shy as me so you
find it you know I used to say getting
Martin out of a meeting I read of a
venue or out of an event was like
getting trying to get a drunk man out of
a pub because he would want to have the
crack and talk and shake hands with and
swap stories with every single person
and that was his nature and that's one
of the reasons why people think of him
so far